- So the question is will Donald Trump
be able to maintain all of the benefits
of being a President
when he leaves office?
Things like a pension,
things like a secret service
detachment to protect him.
Well, the answer is maybe, but probably.
A lot of this is defined by
the Former Presidents Act,
which defines a former
President as someone
who shall have held
the office of President
of the United States of America
and whose service in such office
shall have been terminated
other than by removal pursuant
to Section Four of Article
Two of the Constitution.
So, in other words, you
get all the benefits
of the Former Presidents Act
so long as you weren't removed pursuant
to a trial after impeachment.
So it seems like if Donald Trump resigned,
he'd still get the benefits
of the Former Presidents Act
and he'd get all of those benefits
so long as he isn't removed pursuant
to the Senate trial of impeachment,
and as I've covered before,
that seems incredibly unlikely.
Fellow legal commentator, Richard Hoeg,
has done a whole video about it
and he goes into great detail
about the Former Presidents Act.
I recommend you check it out,
and there's always, I'll see you in court.